oh yeah there's a couple of Studios that
should wait why getting around this cool
alright so Jack he said Jack where we
read you grew up where you're from
originally I was born bred and trapped
in Boston Massachusetts happy childhood
my parents stayed together and that type
of thing at a brain they uh they weren't
drinkers or drug addicts or anything
like that that's a that's a pretty solid
chocolate pretty solid childhood my dad
to get sick when I was younger any fast
way when I was young so that was what
was my thing below but aside from that a
very normal childhood and I moved to LA
in the early 2000s I uh
I actually started and I went to a
vacation in Las Vegas and it just
happened to be a VN week I didn't know
what eevn was you know but watch porno
but I wasn't really that into the baby
the Adult Video News Awards yeah it's
kind of like our Oscars Independence
news auspices so um so I found myself
was casino with all these people in the
adult industry and seen how much fun
they were have in his class pretty cool
you know so I kind of sparked my that
times 29 at that time you know a young
you know I guess a normal standards but
kind of get the adult industry it's kind
of getting old to start you know but I
got the idea in the back of my head and
at the time I was working construction
hazardous waste removal work
and just really unhappy with my life was
going i says a snowstorm one day and I
was out of work and sit there watching
Showtime with my and my girlfriend at
the time and and I see this documentary
it's called pornucopia and then if
there's all these Delta Delta industry
figures
Tommy Gunn and Brad Armstrong jessica
drake all these haven't stolen all these
types of people and now i'm watching
this documentary and they're talking
about how great la is you know how they
all have this fantastic lifestyle they
have sex of all these people who paid
money for the nice houses as [ __ ] the
hell am i doing in Boston so I'm
watching TV and I've seen all these
people enjoying this great life and I
look at my girl I said what the hell
these people do and I can't do she said
well for one they live in Los Angeles
no no maybe something what the way she
said it you know like they looked on the
moon or something you know I mean like
this unpossible place I could never get
to Los Angeles and it's up about that
Mitali just the back of my head I didn't
sleep all night it really got to me and
uh I didn't want to be one of those
people just trapped in Boston you know
so next day I went to work after twelve
years I gave my boss my notice but two
week notice and they wish me luck and
and I did I moved out here to Los
Angeles and me my girl bottom the adult
industry and the time we're kind of
naive we thought we can do it together
just work with one another and find out
very quickly that's not how it works
here but it's good in a few months I had
met a few people you know we shot for a
couple different directors and one day
and you get a phone call and someone's
birthday
so director says hey I'm gonna swing by
my limo and grab you're gonna go to a
club you know Tommy gun's birthday holy
[ __ ] you know it's a big guy in the
industry so the limo comes and I never
been in a limo before you know I didn't
go to my prom or anything and uh the
door opens up and in the glow most
jessica drake and gran armstrong Tom you
know all these people that were you know
in the documentary that I just watched
three four three four months earlier
I'm gonna say that it was easy but I
just but it didn't take very long you
know I just had to get off my ass and
make it really a real effort and come
out here and do it and then from there I
just have so many great people yeah
that's pretty much how I entered the
industry in your major I did well you
laughs the were the first people I met
it also in addition that was a ron
jeremy
everyone's a ron jeremy fan you know it
as movies my dad had old stag films and
I was a kid nice to sneak in and stand
with me on the VHS tapes that's like I
just when I was a kid I used to be a
little buddy of mine whose father got a
VCR also like the first two guys and my
name wouldn't get him we're gonna pirate
the movies back and forth on the
weekends when our dads were asleep and
so you're like middle school I was
selling bootleg copies of ron jeremy
pornos so i told him that story when i
first became friends with amigo
he's disturbed by it because my age
obviously would uh but yeah it was a
real bonding moment if i know all these
different movies and stuff titles that
like have been out of print for years
you know i sat in a man whose movies I
loved didn't get a daisy-chain and this
one that one and don't tell him it's
terrible but but he was the kind of my
mentor as well he's the one explained to
me they you can't he can't just work
with you girl actually I'll tell her
that stories of good was the first night
I meet him is and was on Halloween night
2004 and it was the Rainbow Room down in
Los Angeles close friend of mine met
that morning and told me hey he's gonna
be at this Halloween party so I show up
at the Halloween party I introduce
myself my girl and tell him working out
just lose Los Angeles in the adult
industry and you know I know a couple
people the common people that we knew so
at the end of the night the clubs closed
and he says well what do kids doing and
I said uh Wes Wolfe and as with the
person I was also with it's kind of like
they say she's a really close friend and
almost like family say sister for
example
so uh so soon as we say we're gonna go
back to the hotel where you have right
down the street blah blah blah he says
okay he goes well I hope the guys your
honor
cool is that right ron jeremy hang up
ron jeremy [ __ ] yeah so we get back to
the the hotel and i want to take a
picture with them right but this time
cellphones didn't have cameras yet mm so
uh
Sanga one of those digital camera type
of things well it did be the new digital
camera so old is to say so he says uh
the batteries of detonate he goes out
don't worry just does a gas station
across the street Oh Mitch the batteries
don't wait here oh cool I'm all thinking
the time like I'm leaving basically my
sister and my wife in a room of Ron
Jeremy and I don't know anybody at this
point so I go down the street I get the
batteries I'm coming back I'm all set I
take my photos and I open the door and
there's a both of them sucking his dick
and it's just [ __ ] the reality that
hits me I'm going you know I thought to
myself I should leave I don't know
should I leave should I stay I don't
know what's the right thing to do put
the kitten batteries in the camera and I
thought about and I just had to snapping
pictures and uh luckily my sister she I
felt pretty awkward about it so she left
right away get enough blood sister he
was a very close friend someone I did
not expect a second Ron Jeremy's dick
and the two minutes that I was gone and
so I took the photos and she left my
girl I stayed and she shot a hole sexy
he [ __ ] her I filmed it and at the end
of it he looks at me he goes you know a
kid he goes you might have the career in
this business he goes I thought for sure
when you open that door you're gonna
turn around and walk the [ __ ] out and he
goes with the fact that you're able to
keep your composure and put the kick
batteries in the camera take the photos
he goes you might have what it takes
so that was my person i meeting ron
jeremy
now I know better I'd say that in
Jessica nice up I'd like present
girlfriend now sometimes she with him as
well but this kind of guy he as you know
well yeah so he just want to look make
people I've met this industry so uh him
stormy Daniels good friend of mine yeah
anyway your first seen he did as an
actor in the porn industry was what I
mean with went through your mind is he
were doing it the the first cut of the
first two or three I think we're there
were couples a couple saying so I was
doing what I was doing with my girl
therefore very small companies like no
name no pop companies you know and
that's always cool is that God got the
feel of it it was a little uncomfortable
at first you know that have a stranger
you know behind your ass the camera your
girlfriend that you were being awesome
that came out correct yeah join the
industry yeah yeah we worked together
for six or seven years yeah like totally
normal couple to swing or anything we're
totally normal and yeah was that one
documentary both went no we can do this
so that was very different to now my
girlfriend's having sex with all these
other guys you know but we broke on the
same time and yeah sometimes she'd work
more than me sometimes I'd work more
than her so it was that's that nature of
the industry to the girls sometimes have
shorter shelf life I guess you could say
and how was it - like I've had it how do
your male ego deal with the fact that
your girl was screwing some of the guy
all day and that she's home with you and
you know it was it was it's great
question actually I had had a bunch of
previous relationships and it always
ended up with a girl cheating on me so I
had I definitely had a sensitive yeah
there you go when it came to that
depending on there's people like Ron
Jeremy and those sides need fix me know
once you got to understand the nature of
the business and they say you gotta let
go of this you can't just work with her
you're gonna have some [ __ ] other chicks
and that's a good thing and she's gonna
[ __ ] these other dudes and but also what
was different about the adult industry
back then when I started and I've had
many directors tell me this back then
they they wanted male talent to have a
girlfriend in the industry with them by
that me like you look nowadays any guy
can just really good-looking guy can
just get in there and an agent will take
them on back then you had to have a girl
to go in with you and the reason being
they just explained is if some days I'm
going to be what I might be working with
the directors life and then the next
week you might be working with my wife
so is that common respect thing and I
miss that about the adult industry a lot
actually I think it's that's changed now
like I said now if anybody can show up
and if people come from all different
walks of life and some people come up
with a crossover from the gay side the
adult industry the crossing to our side
and that's just chaos you don't know who
you working with you don't know
if they're what they're doing in their
private life they're escorting if
they're if they're if they're doing
high-risk I guess that's a muscle PC way
I can say it
hi well need uh the gay side adults
industry a lot of them don't test oh
it's a lot performance are hiv-positive
that risk factors no up they say
according to the AIDS Healthcare
Foundation sixty percent sixty percent
increase your chance of contracting HIV
by working with crossover performers and
another reason is that the escalating
there's a big part of as well um when I
started back in the early 2000s I'm not
gonna say the girls needle Center Street
in escort because that wouldn't be true
but it wasn't uh it wasn't so widespread
it wasn't it wasn't accepted you know I
remember to be girls if you caught it
find out they were escorting and I could
put them on no list so and so I found
out turning tricks I don't to work with
her and that was acceptable you know
that's all thrown out the window now
that's all old school thinking now now
you're some sort of a bigot or
narrow-minded if you don't want to just
put your dick in anyone so and that
part's really bothers me
there's a girl just recently August aims
long rest her soul she was a really
sweet girl and she made a choice she
didn't want to work with crossover
performer and she made a mistake of
letting people know and I've got on
Twitter and next thing you know he had
top industry people attacking this girl
cyberbullying and she hung herself that
night to kill herself
it was odd because she didn't want to
work to serve before because she felt
these high rates
so it's
I wish that part I wish people are so
politically correct these days more
health conscious and more hey you know
what it is what it is this person's
doing this and a high risk I have the
right to choose whether or not I won't
work with them without their being
attacked how was your career affected
your personal relationships um or do you
date people in the industry and I've
headed what your adult industry I find
this I mean I couldn't imagine trying to
date a civilian and that's what we call
people at docking point yeah I think I
don't think of whatever works and
examples that I see other people in the
industry to try it it never works
you know say for an example a girl some
girls so they don't want a date a porn
guy because you know there's a bunch of
different reason to get to in a second
but uh they tried to eating outside the
adult industry you know the beginning of
guys oh yeah wow I'm dating this hot
corn [ __ ] she'd have big tits and she
doesn't listen and after a week or two
they start to realize like hey the girl
I'm dating is a porn chick and she's out
there [ __ ] these other guys and then
they start to get you know it's cure and
they're in that type of thing and the
next thing you know the girl being the
girl will have a promising career doing
really well for herself will all of a
sudden Taylor agent hey I'm not gonna do
boy girl anymore I'm not gonna do this
I'm not gonna do interracial anymore
that's another one that you know and
they gotta catch that home raft a ship
for that for being racist but uh but
yeah you'll have a girl with a
successful career and the next thing you
know she just doing girl girl or maybe
not even working at all well I call them
four killers that's my pet name for
those guys but yeah it's great question
your mask actually it's tough to be in
the adult industry cuz you have to date
other drug performers there's no one
else to get aget it
you know late thing I've taken a little
time off it's good to take breaks in
this business you can wear yourself up
pretty easy so I step behind the camera
of doing doing a lot of stuff behind the
camera it's allowed me to enjoy sex
again because for a while for a long
while
in the beginning of my career I was
working 15 to 20 scenes a month
sometimes it's a lot of work for me some
guys work more some guys work everyday I
don't know how those guys do it they
must have Teflon on their dick or
something I don't know but I can do that
do you can't be intimate with your
significant other because it's like oh I
have a scene on Tuesday and Thursday
what one do you work oh I kept seats at
all it's an anal seam so I got a prep
but not all this so it's like you're
trying to literally trying to spend
trying to plan intimate moments with
your significant other and it makes it
not organic anymore makes it not just
that whole intimacy just separate out of
your leadership so I think that's one of
the biggest problems I have with a sign
of balance of having good healthy
productive sex life at home with my
significant other it is still being able
to you know go out a few days a week and
really hit home runs during the scenes
it's it's very stressful
thousands of dollars sometimes on the
line
for a man it's a little different for
female so did you have to take a drug or
something - is they sure sure yeah yeah
that's definitely a big difference
meeting the guys on the girls the girls
then I have a good day that's gonna put
a little Lube on the vagina and then off
they go
but with a guy I'm sitting there [ __ ]
limp noodle it's a big problem
I gotta say in a second ago you'd be on
except for someone separate I go and
said I go to work one day any day you
show up at work maybe something's going
with me to liquid car payment you fight
with the girl
Morgan is late whatever maybe get that
little stress in the backyard you know
and as I seen such that you know you get
to it it takes half mass or it's not you
know it's not worth it's not a hundred
percent it gets in your head immediately
and it might have been just I don't know
a little pickup is now turning this any
minds you're into this massive problem
and just sitting there and looking to
start a fire jerking off and you know
you see the look on the directors face
to the pane for location to be for
makeup artist lighting guys you know
cameraman you know depending what you
shoot before it's like a wicked but
pictures movie or something you could
have a five ten thousand dollar day if
[ __ ] go to waste because you can't
keep it up yeah you know I'll share this
one because people probably won't think
I will share this one but uh this is
probably what Andres favorite I was
doing scene and as forceful me Daniels I
was a production manager at the time and
and the schedule got screwed up and I
Hanif I supposed to do my scene in the
morning that's when I work best and and
get it done and then have the rest of
the day to be production manager
time and got screwed up I had to my
scene in like midnight by this time I
was tired it's you know he's not feeling
it in a total lipstick could not get it
if it girls nothing gets a girl she was
beautiful she was accommodating all that
but I just love noodles so I went to one
of the guys uh on set and I said hey do
you have an extra viagra I need someone
to help me out they said I don't use the
viagra right I use cabbage act so those
you don't kappa jaque didn't say it's an
injectable and it's mostly used people
paralyzed people will the VD problems so
you take this needle and you shove it in
your dick and 90 seconds later it's it's
rock hard and it doesn't matter if
you're horny or not you just get this
and it's uncomfortably higher to it so
it's not it's not a fun feeling it's
really difficult to come you can always
tell the guy who's on camera yet because
the stick will be hired as soon as he
comes out of the bathroom and then two
hours after the scenes over he's still
walking around with his dick still hard
and you're like okay you know easy to
see what you did so back to me I'm
sitting there and I got this contemplate
I've only shot my dick up a few times
throughout my whole career but I got to
do it yeah it's one of these $5,000 days
you know five thousand plus dollar days
so I'm in the bathroom innum ennum get
the needle and do the nervous my hands
are shaking like a leaf I can't do this
I can't do it No so uh so I gotta go
back out and I said the storm user
directory a stormy could you come here
for a minute
so she looks at me she said oh are you
something it will piss on a piane or
something I do something kinky like what
the [ __ ] do you expect me to do this no
I'll just come in I need help so she
comes to the bathroom and now that
everyone look at the camera men my age
and Andre he's outside everywhere the
whole everyone can hear what's going on
and so I show her the rig and I said hey
Lucy you gotta help me shoot my she went
[ __ ] fine I help you can dig up for
it so we get the director you know I
said I can't see look at my hands
shaking like I'm chain-link fences have
you got to help me so she said okay so
now that she's on ease like it stormy
Daniels on her knees in front of me with
this [ __ ] needle and it reminds me
all of something like that scene in Pulp
Fiction you know like you know go on the
count of three like one you know just
don't hit a vein so uh so she shoots my
dick up and now I'm nervous I'm
embarrasses [ __ ] you know everyone that
everyone in the building knows that like
you know I'm having a bad day and what's
come - and I come up and this miracle
drug that's that everyone takes likes a
quadriplegic and take it in their dick
looking hard my dick is still 50/50 of
best it's still flats it oh they're so
stressed so so storm you said you know I
talked to the location owner try to work
it out leave the equipment we'll come
back tomorrow you should maybe get some
sleep India doesn't food you stomach war
have a better day tomorrow so I said
okay great
that's embarrassing but assume I don't
want to keep their dough in there all
night so we do that
I leave come back to like 8 o'clock next
morning and everything's fine my dick
works fine
what's clip see there's actually but the
pretty damn good scene and the female
talent she's like well Jesus
well the difference right I said yeah
yeah so I'm all happy I'm smiling I'm
getting the clothes on stormy looks at
me and she says uh she says what the
[ __ ] you smiling about
I said why did the scene it came out
really good you know I just killed it
and she goes oh you do think about this
she goes up
she's we're over budget my whole day and
she says you're the production manager
she goes that means you have to go to
the board and you have to sit in a room
big room full office well board members
of you know all the big shots they own
the company explain to them while we're
over so that's uh that's what we got to
do I gotta get in the car I got to drive
over there and tell drew all these
employers and all these these tough guys
the first thing they did the accountant
looks and he says we're over a deal what
happened and I'm just about to I'm on a
break in the news like well it's
just blurts out his dick didn't work
didn't work we had to come back and
reshoot it so uh so the guys with all
the guys that were in the room oh no
that's terrible you know Wow I feel bad
for you wasn't wasn't the end of world
it was loosely uh there was one of those
humiliating days where you just gotta
suck it up and go but am I gonna quit
over it learn from it and hopefully yeah
but it's inside since it does bruise
your ego and he's got to get up and if
when you fall you see mister you got to
get up and move on and if you don't you
gonna last long
and everyone has good days everyone has
bad days no you're bad again but you
know it's the council thanks a lot thank
you so much for talking to me
honestly if you didn't tell other people
at scenario hey I got a tiger a million
stories so I was great great stories
well thank you so much Adam